you look phenomenal Wow
thank you so much just a little at home
drag you got nominated for an Emmy
nomination which is absolutely amazing
we have to celebrate but this is huge
because it's a historic moment as an
acting category this is a big moment for
the lgbtq+ community what does that mean
to be able to make this moment happen
I'm glad that I can be somebody who if
there's a 17 year old kid somewhere else
going like I don't know what I want to
do who she looks pretty maybe I'll do
that I have no one coming to this
wedding no one my family cast me out
when I was 15 and lord knows I don't
give up about any of these people I
actually have two nominations right now
too because I did my own makeup so I'm
also nominated for mix yeah why do you
think your character was so important so
many people usually wear a punch line or
a quick like best friend or something
it's never usually just like a focus on
a character you know when you think
about the industry itself and creating
opportunities for queer performances and
creators how can that be done I don't
even have an agent for acting I thought
oh after stars born I'll get an agent
nope nobody cares I've always just been
all about making my own stuff instead of
waiting for someone else to be like ooh
do you want a job here's three lines I'm
like let me do this myself
I think waiting for your own stories to
get told is fine but like making them
happen on your own is a little bit
better
woolum also told his side of the story
recently after Glee star Lea Michele was
called out for making her co-stars lies
a quote living hell on set Willam was
set to appear on the hit musical series
but quit after a brief encounter with
its star you talked about on Twitter
about Lea Michele and you use the word
subhuman that really got my attention
yeah why use that term what happened to
make you feel that way because if
someone says something to you the main
response is usually to respond back
she didn't say something back she gave
me a dish she went up
into her phone and I was like oh I was
like no no uh-uh I was like you weren't
on this way anymore and I remove myself
from the situation there's a lot of
people speaking up and acknowledging
their own experiences so I think it was
important for you to speak up gonna be a
37 year old Maria in West Side Story
somebody needed to say something wise
drag such an important political
statement once you put the drag on
you're gonna get more notice so I think
being loud and out there is great at
pride in everything but this year it's
all about like making everybody feel
included because brown and black people
in minority spot for LGBTQ rights which
I definitely am prospering from so how
about I go ahead and do the right thing
which is help supporting them